son las 8:30 de la noche en Bogotá quito
y Lima nosotros continuamos en directo
América edición nocturna a ustedes Les
agradecemos su sintonía y vamos con los
titulares de esta jornada
la Cumbre de líderes de la Unión Europea
finalizó en Bruselas con la guerra en
Ucrania como uno de los temas
principales los líderes acordaron una
mayor ayuda a kiev en artillería al
tiempo que la presidenta de la comisión
europea anunció una conferencia sobre la
deportación de menores ucranianos por
parte de Rusia Tenemos reporte
aumenta la polémica alrededor del caso
del expresidente Donald Trump y la
actriz pornográficas la fiscalía de
Manhattan en Nueva York acusó a tres
representantes republicanos de Iniciar
una investigación sin precedentes sobre
un juicio local pendiente lo que viola
la soberanía del Estado esto luego de
que los legisladores pidieron al fiscal
que entregara información del caso
el presidente de Bolivia Luis Arce
propuso un plan de siete puntos para
relanzar las relaciones de su país con
chile la iniciativa contempla
negociaciones sobre una posible salida
al mar algo que ya fue crítico por
legisladores chilenos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
comenzamos en Bruselas donde tuvo lugar
la Cumbre de líderes de la Unión Europea
que tuvo la migración la situación
económica y la guerra en Ucrania como
centro de la discusión los participantes
también acordaron aumentar la ayuda
militar a Ucrania indicaron que
desarrollarán mecanismos para localizar
a los más de 16.000 niños ucranianos
deportados de manera irregular a Rusia
Esther Herrera corresponsal de France 24
en Bruselas nos dio más información
primer día de Cumbre europea aquí en
Bruselas marca de inevitablemente por la
guerra en Ucrania que se produce Poco
después de la orden de arresto
internacional contra Vladimir Putin por
crímenes de guerra por haber participado
supuestamente en el secuestro de niños
ucranianos y llevados forzosamente a
Rusia algo que se considera un crimen de
guerra Según la ley internacional según
la comisión europea aproximadamente
16.000 niños ucranianos han sido
secuestrados y llevados a Rusia al
respecto la presión de la comisión
europea Úrsula founder Legend ha
anunciado una iniciativa junto con el
Primer Ministro polaco mateus Mora
viequi en que habrá una conferencia
Próximamente para arrojar luz sobre este
crimen de guerra y también poder
aumentar la presión internacional una
medida que tiene el apoyo del secretario
general de la ONU Antonio Gutiérrez con
el que los líderes europeos han podido
aquí en Bruselas en quien ha hablado de
las consecuencias de la Guerra de
Ucrania los líderes europeos también han
hablado por videoconferencia con el
presidente ucraniano vlodemir
excelentski quien ha pedido más armas
más municiones y más rapidez los líderes
europeos de hecho han ratificado
una nueva propuesta que se aprobó esta
misma semana para enviar un millón de
municiones en los próximos 12 meses a
Ucrania y acelerar la producción de
armamento la reunión de hoy de líderes
europeos Se ha producido Poco después de
que el presidente chino
haya viajado a Moscú para presentar su
plan de paz y aunque los líderes
europeos se muestran cautos al respecto
sí que han coincidido todos en que para
que china se convierta en media hora
debe hablar antes con Ucrania
Francia vivió otra jornada de
manifestaciones ciudadanas más de un
millón de manifestantes salieron a las
calles de manera pacífica en rechazo a
la reforma al sistema de pensiones hacia
el final de las marchas la atención
entre los ciudadanos y las fuerzas de
seguridad de escaló más de 170 personas
fueron detenidas 77 de ellas en París
la ciudad de las luces de nuevo en
llamas
los manifestantes salieron a las calles
de París por noveno día consecutivo este
jueves y al caer la noche Se registraron
incidentes violentos
a primera hora más de un millón de
manifestantes en su mayoría pacíficos
marcharon por toda Francia
indignados no solo por la reforma de las
pensiones que ampliará la jubilación de
los 62 años a los 64 sino también por el
uso de poderes especiales por parte del
presidente la semana pasada que forzó la
aprobación del proyecto de ley sin el
voto de la asamblea nacional
el gobierno ha aprobado esta ley con un
poder que le permite la constitución
pero mi generación nunca votó por esta
Constitución no está bien Queremos otras
formas de gobierno algo que sea legal el
procedimiento del 49.3 no es legítimo
ante el depósito de petróleo de
estibadores y sindicalistas de la cgt se
manifestaron luego que las autoridades
los intentaran obligar a volver al
trabajo el suministro de queroseno en la
capital se encuentra bajo mínimos los
políticos también salieron a la calle el
líder del partido verde lanzó flores a
las fuerzas de seguridad para denunciar
la violencia
amnistía internacional ya manifestado su
preocupación por el uso excesivo de la
fuerza y las detenciones arbitrarias
algo de lo que se hace eco la alianza
parlamentaria de izquierda nupes
una tenemos una deriva autoritaria no es
Polonia no es Hungría pero los
republicanos en su conjunto están
derivando hacia la derecha lo que es
extremadamente preocupante
los sindicatos ya han convocado nuevas
huelgas y protestas para el martes que
podrían perturbar una visita prevista
del Rey británico Carlos III
continuamos en Israel donde la
controversial reforma judicial del
Primer Ministro Benjamin de tanyahu
volvió a desatar protestas este jueves
con oferta operativo policial desplegado
para contenerlas esto luego de que el
mandatario indicara en una entrevista
televisada que quiere encontrar una
solución con el mayor consenso posible
al rechazo se suma una ley aprobada
durante la madrugada de hoy que blinda
netanyahu de la posibilidad de ser
recusado o declarado no apto para
ejercer su cargo mientras se enfrenta un
juicio por presunta corrupción
haré todo para calmar la situación y
terminar con la división entre la gente
porque somos hermanos
la reforma judicial es una reforma
judicial para la democracia tiene que
proporcionar una solución a las
necesidades básicas de todos
para evitar una fractura entre nuestro
pueblo ambas partes deben tener en
cuenta los reclamos y preocupaciones de
las otras partes
en Estados Unidos El fiscal del distrito
de Manhattan Alvin quien lleva adelante
la investigación en contra del
expresidente Donald Trump por el pago en
secreto a la actriz pornográfica stormy
Daniels calificó como una intromisión la
citación emitida por algunos
representantes republicanos en el
congreso por otro lado el ex jefe de la
Casa Blanca Donald Trump cuestionó la
actuación del fiscal a través de
mensajes en su red social calificandola
como un plan de lunáticos de la
izquierda radical
se mantiene firme en su investigación y
cualquier movimiento de los republicanos
para defender al expresidente deberá por
lo menos ser acordado Y es que la
oficina del fiscal de distrito de
Manhattan rechazó una citación de tres
presidentes de comités republicanos para
ofrecer detalles confidenciales de la
investigación contra Trump su carta con
fecha del 20 de marzo del 2023 en
contraste es una consulta sin
precedentes en un procedimiento judicial
en marcha a nivel local la carta sólo
llegó luego de que Donald Trump creara
una falsa expectativa de que podría ser
arrestado al día siguiente y sus
abogados les surgieran intervenir ningún
hecho es una base legítima para la
investigación del Congreso la
solicitudes de la carta son una
incursión ilegal en la soberanía de
Nueva York la jurisdicción de
investigación del Congreso se deriva y
está limitada por su poder para legislar
sobre asuntos federales la carta rechaza
una investigación del partido
republicano iniciada días después de que
Trump predijera su propio arresto debido
a una investigación en su contra por el
pago de 130 mil dólares a una actriz del
cine para adultos realizado antes de su
triunfo electoral en el año 2016 un pago
que podría traducirse en falsificación
de registros comerciales fraude fiscal o
violación a la ley de financiamiento de
campañas Trump reaccionó en contra del
fiscal brack con duros mensajes en su
red social porque Brad no abandona este
caso todos dicen que no hay delito no
hice nada mal todo fue compuesto por un
loco condenado con cero credibilidad que
ha sido cuestionado por profesionales
respetados en todo momento bracket se
niega a parar a pesar de la abrumadora
evidencia él es un animal apoyado por
soros que simplemente no le importa el
bien o el mal no importa cuántas
personas sean heridas Esto no es un
sistema legal esto es la gestapo esto es
Rusia y China pero peor vergüenza por
este caso se espera que el gran Jurado
retome actividades el próximo lunes
mientras los opositores al ex presidente
manifestaron este jueves en las afueras
de la oficina del fiscal sin embargo
este no es el único Torbellino que
afronte el aspirante a la contienda
electoral en 2024 ya que es posible una
investigación en el estado de Georgia
por los esfuerzos de Trump para una
subversión electoral
el presidente de Estados Unidos Joe
biden llegó a Canadá se trata de su
primera visita oficial a su vecino del
Norte desde que llegó a la casa blanca
se espera que el mandatario Converse con
el Primer Ministro canadiense Justin
trudoso sobre un panorama general a
nivel internacional en el contexto de la
invasión rusa a Ucrania también Ambos
líderes conversarán sobre la disputa con
China y la crítica situación política de
seguridad y economía que vive Haití
Asimismo se espera que aborden el tema
migratorio en el continente americano
entre otros temas bilaterales
en otras noticias el presidente de
Bolivia Luis Arce aseguró que quiere
Iniciar una nueva etapa con chile el
mandatario anunció un plan de siete
puntos para restablecer sus relaciones
con el país austral que incluye negociar
sobre la explotación de litio la
inmigración y claramente sobre el acceso
al mar para analizar esta información
conectamos con Andrés Guzmán Escobar y
analista de temas internacionales
experto en relaciones de Bolivia y chile
Bienvenido a France 24 en estos momentos
chile y Bolivia cuentan con gobiernos de
izquierda puede que esta situación
favorezca de alguna manera una agenda de
negociación por ejemplo sobre el acceso
al mar
Buenas noches
no dudo mucho que esto contribuya las
afinidades ideológicas
generalmente
han contribuido a los acercamientos pero
los intereses nacionales están por
encima sobre todo desde el lado de chile
así que lo veo muy difícil y lo que se
ha planteado hoy día ha sido
prácticamente una
proposición de parte de Bolivia pero que
no ha sido en ningún caso negociada con
chile ni todavía pronunciada o aceptada
de parte de chile entonces
aún cuando existen estas afinidades
ideológicas de izquierda es muy difícil
que esto trascienda en una mejora de las
relaciones ni mucho menos en resolver el
tema más candente y difícil que tenemos
entre Bolivia y chile que es el tema del
mar
Bueno y qué tan factible ya usted lo
estaba mencionando Pero qué tan factible
es llegar a acuerdos Si vemos que por
ejemplo ya parlamentarios chilenos
criticaron este plan de siete puntos de
Arce
es que por eso digo que es muy difícil
porque no hay un ambiente en chile para
aceptar lo que Bolivia ha planteado y es
un mensaje un discurso dirigido al
pueblo boliviano claramente y no así un
mensaje para iniciar una negociación
porque claramente ya se sabe de hecho
que chile va a rechazar tocar el tema
del mar en específico y eso imposibilita
cualquier acercamiento que se pueda
tener y mucho más difícil aún para el
restablecimiento de relaciones
diplomáticas que es algo de lo que
siempre se habla en estos casos no hay
ambiente en Bolivia para eso y creo que
tampoco lo habría en Chile Bueno y qué
otros temas generan discrepancias entre
Bolivia y chile y serían clave en una
eventual negociación
bueno son muchos temas de hecho el tema
del silala que es un recurso hídrico que
ha estado en la Corte Internacional de
Justicia es un tema que no se ha
resuelto aún a pesar de haber atravesado
el proceso también hay otros recursos
hídricos como el río lauca y el río
caquena que han sido desviados hacia
chile y sobre los cuales no hay tampoco
solución y además de eso está el tema
del cumplimiento del tratado de 1904 que
hoy lo ha referido también el presidente
Arce en cuanto a la aplicación del libre
tránsito que chile le debería otorgar a
Bolivia que no se cumple en los puertos
el ferrocarril arica la paz que también
no funciona hace más de 20 años el
minado de la frontera y muchos otros
asuntos en que tienen que ver con el
narcotráfico el contrabando incluso
ahora la migración que también es un
tema que le preocupa mucho a Chile que
son los temas que están sobre la mesa
pero que todavía no han podido ser
resueltos porque no hay un canal de
diálogo y no una buena relación entre
los dos países Pues el señor Guzmán a
usted muchas gracias por su análisis y
por compartirlo compartirlo con nosotros
en France 24
Claro que sí gracias a ustedes y todo
está listo en República Dominicana para
el inicio de la edición número 28 de la
Cumbre iberoamericana que se celebrará
entre el 24 y 25 de marzo bajo el lema
Juntos por una iberoamérica justa y
sostenible se reunirán en Santo Domingo
la capital las delegaciones de cerca de
22 países de latinoamérica y Europa al
menos 14 jefas y jefes de estado y de
gobierno han confirmado su participación
en esta Cumbre uno de los primeros en
arribar a territorio dominicano fue el
presidente de Portugal Marcelo rebelo de
Sousa el mandatario europeo fue recibido
por el presidente dominicano Luis
abinader en el Palacio Nacional y allí
firmaron un acuerdo de promoción de la
cooperación en ámbitos como la economía
la ciencia y la cultura France 24 tendrá
un cubrimiento especial desde Santo
Domingo con nuestras enviadas especiales
tanto en nuestra señal de televisión
como nuestra página web y en todas
nuestras redes sociales
así llegamos al final de esta emisión de
directo América aquí en France 24 a
ustedes Les agradecemos su sintonía y
los invitamos a continuar con nosotros
que ya llega Paula Jiménez con toda la
información del continente asiático en
Así es Asia feliz noche para todos
[Música]